اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير متابعينا اهلا
بكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
بين موسكو واكياف حرب مسيارات مشتعله تطور
استراتيجي يحقق الاهداف ام اختبار يكشف
القدرات الدفاعيه للطرفين
بعد عقد من القطيعه مصر وتركيا تقرران
البدء الفوري في ترفيع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه هل هي خطوه اولى نحو مصالحه
كامله
من الخدمات تمشي لاهلنا وبين طرف يا صراع
السوداني خمسه ايام من الهدنه هل ستنجح
مساعي الوصول الى وقف دام لاطلاق النار
رغم الانتهاكات المتواصله
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
ضمن استراتيجيه تتماشى مع جغرافيا المواقع
تستمر الحرب في اوكرانيا الدبابات
والمنظومه الدفاعيه على الارض وطائرات
بدون طيار في كل من المجال الجوي الروسي
والاوكراني حيث اصبحت هذه المسيرات
المتفجره سلاحا اساسيا في النزاع الدائر
فكل من الجانب الروسي والاوكراني كذلك
يحاول في الفتره الاخيره تكثيف الهجمات
المضاده بالطائرات المسيره حتى وصلت الى
عواصم البلدين اي موسكو وكياس خطوه يمكن
ان تؤثر على مسار مواجهه العسكريه وعلى
تغير في امد الحرب واستنزاف الطرفين ماديا
ومعنويا وفق مراقبين هذا التطور
الاستراتيجي تزايد خلال مايو بعدما اسقطت
روسيا طائرتين مسيرتين كانت تستهدفان
الكريم
وقتها كياف بالوقوف وراء هذا الهجوم بينما
نفت اوكرانيا ان تكون لها علاقه به في
بدايه الحرب استطاعت روسيا استخدام
المسيرات بشكل جيد في قصف البنا تحتيه
الاوكرانيه وكذلك محطات توليد الكهرباء
ولكن الدعم الغربي جعل كيف تتغلب على ذلك
حيث تمكنت اوكرانيا من استخدام المسيرات
بشكل عمليتي افضل من خلال قصف مواقع تؤثر
على لوجستيات الجيش الروسي وخلال هذا
الصراع تمتلك روسيا واوكرانيا انواعا
مختلفه من المسيرات ولذلك سيكون الرهان
كما يكون مراقبون على من له قدرات دفاعيه
اكبر وانظمه رادار احدث لوقف مواجهه
الدرونز
حرب المسيرات تشتعل بين روسيا واوكرانيا
ابرز المسيرات المستخدمه من كلا الطرفين
طائرات برقدار تركيه الصنع اوكرانيا تعتمد
اساسا على طائرات اوكرانيه الصنع طول
جناحها يبلغ 32 قدما تطير لسبع ساعات
بسرعه 100 ميلي بالساعه
طائرات امريكيه الصنع تطير لست ساعات
بسرعه 100 ميل بالساعه
روسيا هي الاخرى تملك مسيرات متطوره اهمها
اوريان ثابته الجناح بطول 14 مترا تطير
لاربع وعشرين ساعه متواصله بسرعه 120 ميلا
بالساعه وسيارات تشاهد الايرانيه سرعتها
تبلغ 185 كيلومترا بالساعه تبلغ هدفها عبر
نظام جي بي اس
مناقشه هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكوس
المحلله العسكري اهلا بك من كافه سفير
فلوديف
اهلا بكم ضيوفى الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من موسكو مع سيد شاشكووف في لغه
ميزان القوه العسكريه من حيث امتلاكا
مسيرات وخاصه القدره على استغلالها
والانتفاع فيها من المتفوق موسكو او اكياس
مساء الخير جميعا
يجب الاعتراف بان هناك نوع من
التوازن او
التساوي من حيث عاده المسيرات وكيفيتها
وفعاليتها
انتم ذكرتم في البدايه عن المسيرات
التركيه نوع بيركتار وبعد ما داخل هي
الخدمه في صفوف سلاح الجو الاوكراني
كان هناك نوع من الضجيج
وتصريحات رائعه وفرح وسرور بينما الان
اصبح من الواضح ان خاسره اوكرانيا 90% من
تلك المسيرات التركيه ولم تبقى لديها الا
عشره تقريبا طائرات بايركتار وهي لا تقترب
خط الطماس يعني خط الجبهه ويتم استعمالها
بغيه الاستطلاع
من العمق هذا فيما يخص بوزن
المسيرات التركيه المجهوله هذه
من جانب اخر المسيرات التي تستخدمها
اوكرانيا في
الغالات الجويه وخصوصا على العاصمه موسكو
اليوم فجر اليوم كان هناك هجوم ثاني خلال
الشهر هذا
من الناحيه العسكريه ليس هناك جدوى ولا
معنى لا استراتيجيا ولا تكتيكيا ولكن
اعلاميا نعم هناك هذا الحادث لاقي صعد
واسع جدا في مختلف الحاله العلم
فقال الرئيس بوتين تعليقا على هذه الهجمه
ان هذا كان رد الفعل الاوكراني على
الضربات الاخيره التي وجهتها القوات
الصاروخيه الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ولا سيما
في بعض منشات اقتصاديه وعسكريه
في في اوكرانيا وتم تدمير مطار صناعي
الاستخبارات العسكريه العامه وتم التدمير
بعد القواعد الجويه المهابط فيها
ومستودعات الذخيره يعني هناك تبادل من
الضربات هذه اي خطوه من طرف اخر يليها
مقابل
كذلك من طرف روسيا سنعود الى هذا
الاستهداف ولكن حضرتك اعتبرت وهنا سؤال
حضرتك سيد شوماكوف ضيف يقول بانه القدرات
العسكريه الروسيه اقوى بكثير مما تمتلكه
اوكرانيا وضرب مثال قال بانه بمقدار مثلا
هذه المسيرات التركيه المشهوره استنزفت
هذه الحرب تقريبا 90% من عددها الاجمالي
هل يمكن ان يكون هذا المعطى دقيق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه من بدايه
حرب نحن نسمع من المحللين روسها وكمان من
السياسيين
[موسيقى]
الترسانه الاوكرانيه ولكن في نهايه المطاف
اوكرانيا حراره تقريبا 60% من اراضي
الاوكرانيه والان نحن نشاهد بان اوكرانيا
كمان تحقق بصفه عامه هجومات بنجاح
وتستهدف في العمق المناطق المحتله مراكز
قياديه روسيه وايضا مستودعت مع حول
المصايرات خاصه
هل روسيا ضامرت 90 بالمئه او خمسه بالمئه
من
[موسيقى]
مهم جدا هذا هجوم على المسيرات على هذا
غير معروف من حقق هذا او قوات مصالحه
اوكرانيه او فيله
كمان غير معروف ومن اين تم الاطلاق
هذا الموضوع سيدي
يقول اروس بانه اوكرانيا لا تتحمل
مسؤولياتها الكامله بخصوص هذه الاستهدافات
لا تتبنى ولا تتحمل مسؤولياتها ولكن فيما
بعد هناك تعليقات من مسؤولين اوكرانيين
تعليقات غامضه او ساخره نفهم منها بان من
يقف وراء هذا الاستهداف هي اوكرانيا هل
تتخفى اوكرانيا خوفا من مواجهه روسيا فيما
يخص موضوع مسيرات
بصراحه نحن قد تتعوضنا لاتهامات وكمان
لتهديدات روسيه بمناسبه من بدايتها حرب
روسيا اطلقت لاوكرانيا اكثر من الف وخمسون
مصيره وامس بالمناسبه للاسف الشديد في ظهر
روسيا اطلقت على مدينه كييف 11 صاروخ من
طراس اسكندرا يعني عدد السكان مدينه كيف
روسيا
تستخدم الاسكندر اكيد هذا اباده الجماعيه
الشعب الاوكراني نحن لا نخاف الان اي شيء
بصراحه
حضرتك تعلم بان كل هذه الاستهدافات لا
توازي استهداف الكرملين بمعنى اذا تبنت
اوكرانيا عمليه استهداف الكريم قد يكون رد
روسي اقوى من المنتظر
كل يوم نحن هنا نشاهد
بمصائرات وكمان بالصواريخ بالمناسبه اليوم
بعضهم سياسيين كبار روسيا هددوا باستخدام
اسلحه نوويه على اوكرانيا على اوكرانيا
من اجل السلام وروسيا ضمنت حمايه حدود
اوكرانيه حمايه استقلال اوكرانيا ووفقا
للمذاكره
ارهابيه حول هذا الهجومات المصيرات وهنا
نقطه جوهريه بان
بالصفه بصفه اعماقك هذا الهدف استنزاف
روسيا وكل هذا الهجومات هذا الضرر على
بالمناسبه اليوم ستبرجوشن رئيس مجموعه هو
استخدم هذا الفرصه قائلا وهو طاح جيش روسي
والسلطه روسيه بانها بانها عاجزه لحمايه
الجو فوق الموسكو وحمايه سكان موسكو حضرتك
تعتبر بانه هذا هذه الاستادفات تمس من
سمعه بوتين هكذا تقول ما رايك في هذا
الكلام سيد حضرتك منذ قليل وكانك بسطت
قليلا فاستهداف الكريم مثلا اعتبرته بانه
هذا استهداف او يمكن ان تكون له تبعات
اعلاميه ليس اكثر ولكن البعض يرى بان
اوكرانيا لما تستهدف الكرمل فهي استهدفت
سياده الروسيه ولكن روسيا لما استهدفت
استهدفت البناء التحتيه استهدفت
مناطق تحوي على موارد كهربائيه ليس اكثر
الصوره انا العكس تماما
لو نظرنا الى فيديوهات وتقارير المصوره من
العاصمه موسكو فهناك
اصابات لثلاثه عمارات متعدده التوابك يعني
مجمعات سكنيه
وتوجيهها زربه على كريملين يعني هذا رمز
السلطه الروسيه يعني ما هي
ليست هي قاعده عسكريه او او هدف عسكري هذا
مقر القياده السياسيه صحيح ولكن سبق
لاوكرانيا ان استهدفت مثلا مصفاه نفط
لمرتين مناسبتين نفط اليكسي استهدفت كذلك
تحدثت عن قاعده عسكريه استهدفت قاعده
عسكريه جويه في جزيره القرن هذه استهدافات
مهمه
ما حذف مسار اليوم قبل ساعتين تقريبا
القصف الشديد من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
لمجمع سكني في محافظه بنغرد هناك قتلى
والجرحى بين المدنيين الاطفاء والصغار
والكبار
بينما عندما تضرب القوات المسلحه الروسيه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بما فيها الى عصر مكيف فكان بين الاهداف
مستورده الذخيره في مدينه خبيليسكي
ومنصات اطلاق الطائرات صواريخ المضاده
للطائرات في كيف وتم تدمير احدى المنصات
وتم
اصابه بعض المعابد
والقواعد
العسكريه للسلاح الجوي في استرا
وغيرها يعني فرق كبير بين خيار
الاهداف بين
بين
متفوقه طيب لنختم بسؤال يقال بان استخدام
هذه المسيرات هو تكتيك لاطاله امه الحرب
من المستفيد من اطاله امد الحرب لاستنزاف
القوه النفسيه والماديه لخص ما سابدا معك
بصراحه نحن نشاهده بان اوكرانيا كمان دخلت
في حرب حرب المسايارات روسيا مؤمن اكتوبر
هي تستخدم المستشارات المختلفه لتدمير
بنيه تحتيه سكنيه وكمان بني تغطيه للطاقه
الان اوكرانيا كمان ممكن اوكرانيا معروفه
تستخدم بنجاح المسعيرات وخاصه على هجومات
في عمق مناطق المحتله واين اوكرانيا
تستهدف بنيه تخطيط العسكريه ونهون النقطه
الجوهريه اوكرانيا بصفه عامه تستخدم
النقطه جمهوريه تحقيق العسكريه بالمناسبه
روسيا كل يوم تقصف المحافظه خيرسون
والضواحي هذه المدينه كل يوم عندنا هناك
حصيله الضحايا من ثلاثه الى خمسه اشخاص
وروسيا تستهدف هناك مناطق حديديه
ولكن باختصار شديد من المستفيد من اطاله
امد الحرب روسيا اوكرانيا في كلمه
بصراحه اي اضرار لروسيا على المصالح
اوكرانيا مما من المعروف بان اوكرانيا
تستخدم بالمسارات المطارات العسكريه
الروسيه وكمان كمان الخزانات
يعني الان اوكرانيا دخلت في فتره جديده
باستخدام السيارات بنجاح في عمق روسيا
تستفيد من هذه الحرب والمستفيده الوحيده
هو الغرب
وكانت هناك تصريحات رسميه على مستوى رفيع
جدا ان الغرب سيزاود اوكرانيا بكل ما
تحتاج من
الاسلحه والذخيره والمعدات العسكريه
والاموال والى اخره في سبيل استنزاف روسيا
وتدمير روسيا عسكريا في مداد المعركه كان
هناك قرار حلف شمال الاطلسي قائلا انه لا
حل لنزاع هذا الا عسكريا ولا نسمح بهزيمه
اوكرانيا بحل من الاحوال ولكن
في كل حادثه ستاتي في مرحله من المراحل
يتمناها البعض قريبا ساكتفي معكم بهذا
القدر اود شكركم جزيل الشكر على مدى فضلتم
به من موسكو في المحلل العسكري شكرا لك
ومنكوف اديبلوماسي والسابق شكرا لكم
ونتوقف مع فاصل من بعده سنناقش في الملف
الثاني
بعد عقد من القطيعه مصر وتركيا تقاريران
البدء الفوري في ترفع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه هل هي خطوه اولى نحو مصالحه
كامله بعد قليل نناقش هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات